victory over breast cancer could be a
blueprint for future life-saving
treatments she was near death when she
enrolled in a clinical trial that used
an experimental kind of therapy it
unleashed the body's own immune system
to attack the cancer
dr. Jon LaPook is here to show us how
she beat the odds good morning good
morning Nora this particular type of
immunotherapy has been used in a limited
way for certain types of cancer but this
single case represents a breakthrough
for breast cancer and could usher in a
more personalized way to treat other
types of cancer we went backpacking in
Nepal we went rafting down the Grand
Canyon in 2014
Judy Perkins and her husband Bob were
powering through their bucket list after
learning her breast cancer treated a
decade earlier had returned I felt
another lump on the same side and this
time it ended up being Stage four I
entered the world of cancer patient
serious cancer patient
despite hormonal and chemotherapy
Perkins had run out of options the
cancer had spread to her chest and liver
I felt bad for my family but I was
grateful for the life I had had and you
were at the point where you had pretty
much accepted the end but in 2015
Perkins found dr. Steven Rosenberg of
the National Institutes of Health she
probably had two or three months left to
left to live he's a pioneer in
immunotherapy or harnessing immune cells
to fight cancer genetic mutations in the
cancer cells are the trigger causing
those cells to grow out of control
Rosenberg's new approach is to find the
few immune cells called lymphocytes
already in the body that can see those
genetic mutations and multiply them into
an army of cancer killers it's a war
going on at a microscopic level as these
lymphocytes are attempting to find the
cancer expand in number and
the cancer cell in a lab Rosenberg's
team grew those few immune cells into
billions then injected them into
Perkins's bloodstream they're just like
the immune cells appearing white in this
picture they ganged up to attack cancer
cells we're developing a new drug for
every patient that's suitable for that
patient but no other patients back home
Perkins was at first exhausted and then
could actually feel the tumor softening
and then a year later it's all gone I
mean just the odds are so ridiculous
that I mean I did hit the jackpot
it's amazing circulating in her body are
large numbers of the cells we
administered to her two and a half years
ago in March Perkins navigated 1,200
miles around Florida by kayak and shows
no signs of stopping dr. Rosenberg
stresses that this type of personalized
immuno therapy is still in its infancy
two other women did not respond to the
treatment but he envisions a day when a
patient will routinely be treated not
with a drug but with an army of immune
cells specifically targeted to that
person's cancer I just got the chills
very exciting stories it works thank you
John thank you